i'm the senior scientist at the science
district theory of computing uh welcome
and thank you for uh joining us on this
uh richard m carp distinguished lecture
uh the this series of lectures was
established
uh to celebrate the role of sam's
institute founding uh director dick khan
in establishing the field of theoretical
computer science formulating its central
problems and contributing stunning
results in the areas of communication
computation complexity and algorithms uh
we're grateful to the many contributors
to the richard m karp found who who fund
who have made this uh series possible
uh i'm delighted to welcome our speaker
today uh kerala bb and uh sean lib uh
kerala bbn is a professor
of applied mathematics and the head of
cambridge image analysis group at
department of applied mathematics and
theoretical physics
at the university of cambridge she's the
director of cantab capital institute uh
for mathematics self information as well
as the epsrc center for mathematical and
statistical analysis of multimodal
clinical imaging she's a fellow of the
jesus college cambridge and the
co-leader of the university images
network
kerala bbn holds a phd from university
of cambridge and a masters in
mathematics from university of salzburg
she did postdoctoral work at institute
for numerical and applied mathematics at
george august university in gottington
and
has served as a tutoring fellow at
british libraries alan turing institute
her many awards and honors include
philip lever june price and the white
head prize of the london mathematical
society
her talk today is entitled mathematical
imaging from geometric pds
and variational modeling to deep
learning for images
please join me in welcoming kerala bbn
thank you so much for having me today i
would have really loved to be there in
person but
sadly i couldn't
um
so we have to do it like this but uh
thank you so much for inviting me for
this thank you uh prashad for
introducing me so kindly for hosting the
session and thanks everyone in the
audience for coming this morning i've
heard there was some rain so yeah thanks
for um thanks for coming
so
um
this
uh
lecture is really meant as
a broad introduction into mathematical
imaging into this really i think rich
mathematical
uh area
uh that has
it has
so many uh beautiful mathematical
concepts mathematical
uh topics
uh in its pocket for us uh to explore
and uh to develop and to analyze to
study
um
so
i want to give you a glimpse into this
this presentation can really be not more
than just a glimpse
um
so
and please interrupt me anytime
again i'll try to look at the screen
interrupt me anytime you have a question
there
okay so let's go
in media so
i think given uh
the audience uh it's maybe best to start
talking about mathematical imaging by
giving you a definition a
characterization of what it is
so mathematical imaging really
is the study and development of
mathematical methods for image analysis
image processing and inverse problems
and imaging
and this talk is really to
give more details to to
to equip this statement with more
details and lots of examples
of what the different topics and the
application areas are that are arising
in mathematical imaging
but before i do that i really would like
to acknowledge my research group here in
cambridge the cambridge image analysis
group
who are really a wonderful bunch of uh
researchers of phd students and postdocs
who are doing wonderful work and it's so
much fun to work with them so thank you
so much to all um to all of them
and also to all the
uh sponsors uh who are giving us funding
to do what we are doing
from government from industry from
private trusts
thank you
so
talking a little bit about the work that
we are doing here in cambridge you get
actually already
one description higher up of what
mathematical imaging very broadly
speaking is
and so what we are doing here is we are
developing mathematical methods and
associated theory based on pdes
variational models optimization machine
learning
um for solving a wide range of
image analysis image processing inverse
imaging tasks
including image reconstruction from
indirect measurements such as
the arising computer tomography or
magnetic resonance tomography where what
the machine is actually measuring is not
an image directly there is a
mathematical inversion involved in order
to get an image out of this machine
um
other topics are image restoration in
the form of for instance denoising or
deconvolution the blurring of images
making images generally more
better
enhancing the content in these images
then the development of techniques for
image segmentation and
classification all the way to
not just looking at a static image but
looking at dynamic imaging data videos
and solving tasks like automated motion
estimation and object tracking and so on
and so forth
and all this methodology and theory
development is usually very
tightly linked in the work that we do
with a range of applications in the
sciences and in the real world
so including photography digital
photography
remote sensing biomedical imaging arts
restoration forensics material sciences
conservation
and so on and so forth actually lots of
these um uh different things we will see
in the course of this talk okay
okay so let's continue what are we going
to do in the talk this is uh the talk is
roughly speaking structured in these
four boxes
so
um i'm going to start talking about what
kind of problems do we actually want to
solve and you saw them and on the
previous slide and this left
bullet point list but i'll give you some
examples now
um
then we talk about uh
why do we want to solve these problems
so what are the applications and again
one really exciting
um aspect of mathematical imaging is
that images are everywhere
and as you saw in this right column
applications are super diverse so this
is definitely also exciting for a
mathematician to to learn from a lot of
different disciplines and also to
get get what you learned to turn this
back into developing mathematical
imaging models
um and then of course we talk about you
know challenges that we need to overcome
if we want to do all of this okay if we
want to solve all these problems and
then last but not least
what are the mathematical approaches and
imaging um that we are solving and that
we're interested in uh and that are
doing all these wonderful things that we
have heard at the beginning
okay and again
here one really beautiful aspect of
mathematical imaging is that there are
various areas in mathematics coming
together
and we will see some examples um of
those
later on
okay so let's go to what do we want to
solve
and uh actually let me just quickly do
one thing because i usually turn on my
timer maybe now 40 minutes because i'm
losing easily track of time okay so when
it rings then 40 minutes are gone we
have maybe five more minutes or
something like this yeah okay
so
problems we want to solve
um
again starting on a high level the
problems we want to solve is that we
want to extract information meaningful
information
from imaging data this information could
come in in the form of an image itself
if you you know if you have a
messed up image and you want to compute
the clean image out of that uh could
come in the form of uh doing some
quantification of this image and so on
and so forth now
um so this is basically what we want to
do so let's look at a few examples one
example is image denoising so image
restoration we have a noisy image and we
want to basically get rid of the noise
and get something that could you know
that that is a good representation of
the clean image
and mathematically speaking this means
we have given um
a noisy image that i call little y that
is the same as the
ground truth the clean image that we
don't know
uh and in the case of uh here of
additive noise uh then we would say this
uh clean this ground truth image has
been corrupted by some random
random component that i call here little
n okay
and uh from this
model i want to compute now a denoised
image used i okay and this could look
like something like this okay depending
on your methodology we'll get later on
to how we're actually going to do this
but roughly speaking you can think of
that this is a decomposition task right
you want to decompose your noisy image
into the noise and the actual intrinsic
structure that is given in the image
another also related to restoration task
is imagine painting
so here the situation is a little bit
different before i had
uh my
image content uh given everywhere so the
image intensity function i know
in this digital image in all the pixels
but it's corrupted okay in image in
painting
part of the image information is lost
okay part of the image is lost part of
the pixels in this image are lost either
because they're damaged
uh in this case someone has drawn over
your photograph or because um there is
an occlusion okay which yeah well an
over drawing you can also consider as an
occlusion there is an object
in front of the actual object you're
interested in okay and you want to
remove this
and so um
again mathematically speaking you can
formulate this like this so you have
given your image
uh inside so in throughout the talk the
domain on which the image is
given in which the image is supported i
call omega but now i have given
the image in not all of the image domain
but
in omega without a sub domain d that in
this case that you see here is uh this
kind of black scribbles okay
and now i want to compute the image in
all of omega so in particular i need to
complete it within this sub domain d
and what you see here is an image
impainting approach in action
um
which in this case as you can see is an
iterative process if you is just to
visualize the fact that what is
happening is that color values
for this methodology in particular are
kind of propagated from the boundary of
this domain inwards okay and it
actually shouldn't take away too much
but in this case it's a pde that is
doing this okay
segmentation segmentation is another
example uh and that again can come in
various forms so the main thing is that
i want i have an image or in this case a
video and i want to
um particular focus on particular
objects in this image now i'm not
interested in everything here but i'm
interested in isolating
segmenting outlining certain objects in
this image in an automated way okay
and so again mathematically you can
formulate this in different ways but
here i'm formulating it like this so we
have given an image you and we want to
compute
the support of an object of interest
that
is inside of the image domain and i want
to uh parametrize this as uh the
characteristic the segmentation itself i
want to parameterize as the
characteristic function of this um
of this spatial domain s okay which is
uh the support of the object of interest
okay
um
okay then the first thing i've mentioned
in this bullet point list is image
reconstruction from indirect
measurements and this is something that
um is a prototypical example also of
what people in inverse problems are
interested in yeah so what you are
the object of interest your physical
quantity which in this case an image
is not what you're directly measuring
but you are measuring some transform
data of this image okay and this
transform could be linear could be
non-linear in the case what you're
seeing here in computer tomography this
transform that i call here
again on the bottom in this mathematical
model here
capital t
is uh in computer tomography uh the
x-ray or radon transform
but could also be other things right
could be
a pde itself like for instance in um
photo acoustic tomography
what actually links that the
measurements to an image are is actually
a pde okay
and so what you need to do in order to
compute the ah and then also the other
thing is of course you
you never have the perfect data but you
always have corruptions and the main
thing also in uh
in this image reconstruction and this
indirect measurements in um
in imaging is that you usually have have
noisy but also under sample data so you
usually acquire less than you actually
want pixels in your image let's say okay
um
okay so this uh this is a really
important task and has lots of you know
you could probably think of lots of
mathematical questions that arise from
that but we'll uh get there a little bit
more later okay but i think that's
enough for now
and then another class of mathematical
imaging topics arise from not looking at
um
one image by itself
and not looking at you know um
uh just uh just quantifying some content
in this individual image or processing
one image but looking at an image data
set and
uh structuring that so so uh grouping um
finding a good clustering of this
dataset into meaningful groups that have
contained some information you're
interested in okay to make this less
cryptic what you're seeing here for
instance is oops
what you're seeing here for instance is
um
a classification approach that
starting with x with chest x-rays
is um um
uh
so you start with chest x-rays and then
your algorithm your classification
algorithm is classifying these chest
x-rays into different pathologies okay
quite a timely topic somehow with the
pandemic around and everything
um particularly with this uh corvette
thing um but here the thing is that we
are looking at uh similarities and also
dissimilarities in this x-rays that uh
that will tell us whether to group
things together into one pathology or
other or uh or whether these are
different pathologies okay and again i'm
not going to talk about this methodology
at the moment now but these are you know
we might come to this later
again okay
um
okay so b this is about what are the
type of problems we want to solve and
now why do we want to solve them
okay and again the type of applications
that might arise are extremely diverse
what you see here is actually one of the
first collaborations that we have been
doing
in cambridge with a zoologist who was a
research fellow in one of the colleges
here and she
was interested in so-called pie fly
catcher birds
and she was in particular interested in
the male uh
part of in the male group of these birds
who have a white blaze on their forehead
and her hypothesis was that somehow the
size of the blaze
is correlated with their sexual
attractiveness of how much they
reproduce okay
uh and there's several funny jokes you
could make about that now but i'll no i
will not but the main thing basically we
helped her to do is to to um uh
to find a way to autumn to automate
um the process of
measuring the size you know
and
and and yeah and and so on that was
quite a nice collaboration
um but let's
talk a little bit about uh other types
of applications of course you know the
medical domain medical research and also
the clinics so the so clinical practice
are big application areas for automating
the analysis of images and to the
processing the enhancement of images
yeah and so in the uh
related to what i've talked about in the
context of image reconstruction
um
so there is of course a lot in medical
imaging here for instance this is posed
on a mission tomography where again the
mathematics are really there to
make to get the most the best image best
depending on the application this the
definition of best could be different
yeah but the best image out of the data
that you measure okay and there is again
just to
remind us there is a lot of ambiguity in
this process because this
uh this indirect uh data this
demographic data is usually noisy and
undersampled okay
uh so compute
putting so mathematical imaging plays a
role to compute really really good
images out of this uh data in the static
case yeah but also
in the dynamic case where the clinicians
are not just interested in
just looking at one you know time
snapshot of of an individual but
actually dynamic processes that are
happening within the human body and
analyzing those and again mathematical
imaging plays a role here in uh both uh
again in this uh tomographic
reconstruction process but then also in
modeling
you know motion and so on uh for
instance uh with partial differential
equations okay
um
image-based diagnosis we have seen this
before i will not talk more about this
but this is definitely
one very important application area to
um
to to to to aid clinicians in making
diagnosis or even
prognostic predictions for patients that
they're seeing by really putting them
into context with a large amount of
history of
of patients that they've seen before um
so be their mathematical imaging is
extremely extremely powerful
um
and then also for automating things in
the clinic which are just tedious for
radiologists to do yeah so
think about as an application area radio
uh
image guided radiotherapy for instance
yeah where organs uh where tumors and
also neighboring organs need to be
outlined in order to uh produce a
treatment planning uh to steer
you know simply speaking the radiation
to the right places and so on and so
here you know
automating things
can really help to do uh can really help
these clinicians oncologists for
instance
okay so this was a glimpse into
biomedical or medical imaging in
particular um
and of course the kind of applications
i'm showing you are anecdotal in the
sense that these are examples of the
kind of things that we are doing yeah
but
we start somewhere right so con
so uh remote sensing
is another really really big uh
application area of mathematical imaging
where we are capturing imaging data from
an airplane or from a satellite and then
we want to make interpretations about uh
our our our earth our
um
our world at scale okay
and uh one collaboration we have uh one
very long-standing collaboration we have
here in cambridge is with the forest
conservation group where we are in
particular interested in looking at
forests from above
and uh in this case what you're seeing
here is lighter data so this is a 3d
point cloud basically taking from an
airplane
that is outlining the shape of what is
underneath of what the surface is is
made of and in this case
this surface is a forest and so what we
have been doing here is helping them
with automatically delineating
segmenting individual trees in this
forest
which has several use cases of course
for them because they can then go
uh you know make the next next step and
analyze the shape of the shapes of these
trees
make
um you know um
make an analysis about size distribution
different species possibly that they can
detect by just looking at the shapes and
so on and so forth and they can also
monitor it and of course how forests are
changing over time
so lots of different use cases for that
lidar is one example for remote sensing
another one is hyperspectral imaging
data for instance where
what you're capturing uh from again an
airplane or a satellite what you're
capturing is
roughly speaking not just an rgb image
but each pixel now has um
has intensity values from a whole lot
from a whole
range of uh intensities within
the light spectrum and so these are
usually 200
more than 200
signatures
you call it also special signatures that
you get per pixel
and these uh spectral signatures give
you an idea of the material that you
have imaged okay of the kind of material
that you have imaged from above
and
again you can do lots of things with
this what
one of the things is of course species
classification
um
where you want to uh use this
hyperspectral imaging data to um
to to divide the image up into uh into
different types of materials into
different in
in the forest into different types of
tree species for instance okay
okay so um yeah then one maybe um
a little bit more unconventional uh area
of applications um
is the digital humanities uh but it's
actually becoming more and more or less
unconventional because let's say it's
becoming more and more conventional
because really digital humanities are a
rich rich rich source
for
uh digital data in particular for
digital images that
need to be you know categorized that
need to be analyzed that in this case uh
we want to do a physical restoration of
those
um and this is also a kind of fun
collaboration with um
art conservators and also art historians
from the fitzwilliam museum here in
cambridge
um who are interested in illuminated
manuscripts
and the nice thing about illuminated
manuscripts for us in particular is that
they're usually never touched physically
so digital restoration is really the
only way uh we could we can give an
interpretation we can give a glimpse
into how this
manuscript uh has looked like uh before
having been corrupted in this case uh
what we are i mean maybe the pictures
speak for themselves but in this case
there was some overdrawing that we
removed and this was even you know um
shown in an exhibition in the pittsburgh
museum a couple of years ago and you can
draw this much further than that so you
could you know you can really uh erase
damages uh in these
in these manuscripts in the in these
drawings in the manuscripts or something
that we've done a couple of years ago
for fun um
is with the former phd student of mine
who's whose thesis was on a 3d
conversion for movies so
converting a 2d movie into a 3d movie
and
that if you think about is actually you
can formalize as an image in painting
task because in order to convert a movie
into 3d you need to create a second
viewpoint right
which means you need to look behind
things
if that makes sense so anyway he has
done that with one of the illuminations
in one of the manuscripts which was also
kind of nice
okay so uh this was now all about
what we want to do and why we want to do
it so how do we do it now and let's
quickly just we recapture what the
challenges are if we now uh think about
how what the methodology is the
mathematical methodologies could look
like and what we need to pay attention
when we develop them
and here i always like to
uh
almost quote ibm
who have introduced as a
characterization for big data the four
v's is a couple of years ago so only
that i'm not using the four b's for big
data but for imaging data and because
there are lots of similarities of course
here uh a little bit different
interpretation for images but okay so
what are the four b's
first one is of course volume so imaging
data
is super large
so there are huge amounts of unknowns
it's very high dimensional
um
and it's not just high dimensional you
know because of the number of pixels but
it can also be you know we we are
looking uh possibly a 3d 4d imaging data
where we want to keep also these
dimensions when we are processing data
so we want to capture this
dimensionality also in the processing
algorithms that we developed
so this has an effect definitely on
computational
uh resources and also on the scalability
of course on of the algorithms that we
develop
the next v is variety and we have seen
this these images you know they come
from all kinds of applications and so
they look super different but of course
if we're thinking about developing
methodologies for interpreting this data
for quantifying things like you know
computing and segmentation we want to
find commonalities
that these algorithms can exploit in
order to do the segmentation
and
so on one and we want to exploit
commonalities because we might want to
use the same segmentation algorithm that
segments here uh this histology image
for segmenting the blaze on the pie
flight catcher bird's head
but then also we might want to exploit
the intrinsic differences between these
different types of images to design to
to actually put those
this special information into the
methodologies yeah
okay
um
velocity is another one again related to
um
a demand on our computational methods
they need to be fast enough such that
not the image capture is overtaking it
um and the other one is veracity
uh which is really about
imaging data being messy being noisy uh
being in being imperfect okay in short
so what does this mean for the
methodologies just to quickly
summarize this again because i've said
already some things uh so this we have
just said what are the requirements now
on our algorithms they need to be of
course robust to corruption uh to noise
uh undersampling
gaps in the data
they also
need to uh
to a certain extent um
be universal
in the sense that
in particular thinking about
methodologies which are using
data-driven ideas to derive models
they need
to be able to
not just interpolate on what they have
seen before but really be able to
extrapolate in particular when thinking
about
imaging as a scientific tool where we'll
be really looking at things that we have
not seen before but we want to explore
we want to discover new things
um
and they need to be sufficiently
accurate to meet
diagnostic prediction planning needs and
they need to be computationally
affordable and in particular scalable
okay
okay so how do we do this
now
um
i always like to talk about mathematical
imaging methodologies in the context of
two paradigms
where in particular the second paradigm
is one that has
actually increased in
importance in the field a lot
since since uh since the emergence of
deep learning okay but let's start with
the left hand side so the knowledge
trooping paradigm
is the one where i say i
want to model the solution to my image
processing let's say task
um as a solution to
a mathematical model like a non-linear
pde
or a minimizer of a variational problem
where a lot of
the the functionality and and the reason
why these kind of pdes and variational
models these these
first principle if you want models are
working is this assumption that
what i want to compute from the image
has some kind of spice representation
okay
boils down basically to just a few
geometric features
like edges in an image for instance or
if you want to
speak in you know harmonic analysis kind
of language um
has a
has a spice representation in some kind
of basis or dictionary okay
that's something that appears a lot and
is something that that really makes
these methodologies like pdes and
variational models work
the other paradigm
is data driven imaging where i say i
don't uh formalize
the
um
you know i i i don't solve my problem
through
um
[Music]
a given mathematical model i don't put
you know solution strategies into
equations basically
but i derive
a model
from the data itself
so i start by saying i start with an
extremely generic model i have no idea
what this model should be like i for
instance i start with a highly over
parametrized neural network
and then i have on the other hand a lot
of training data that shows me the kind
of solutions i want this model to
compute and then i tune this model i
customize the model to reproduce this
training data okay
so this is the data driven way in
contrast to
the knowledge driven way
knowledge driven paradigm where i put my
knowledge my understanding of the task
and how i want to solve it into a
mathematical equation so let's talk
briefly
more or less briefly about each of those
and then um i'll
tell you what belief is the most
exciting development somehow is really
at the interface between the two and
this is where we are going to culminate
this lecture because this interface
talking about hybrids between the two
um
would be at another lecture that i think
we don't have time for so let's quickly
talk about each of these paradigms so
the first one is knowledge driven
paradigm and a prototypical example
we've seen this before is variational
regularization or are these variational
models
and so how does this work what does this
mean and i i think it's easiest to
explain by just focusing on the task of
image denoising okay so
what i'm uh this we've seen before this
is my noisy image this is the clean
image this is noise and i want to
compute some
an approximation to this clean image
okay and one way to do this is to to
model the approximation to the clean
image as a minimizer of an energy
functional
where this energy functional
usually consists of two terms capturing
two things i assume to understand about
the problem
one is the so-called data discrepancy
term and that in the most cases let's
say is just a least squares fit between
the noisy image and your denoised image
so you you you say okay in some sense my
my clean image should still be close to
the noisy image
and then this is complemented by
something now that should get rid of the
noise right and that is the so-called
regularization term that uh smoothes uh
the noisy uh image y in a way that
attenuates um
erases attenuates the noise uh in y and
gives you a clean image you and then
these two terms uh
and maybe i should say so one example
again so this this kind of smoothing
procedure takes advantage of
um
saying that the image the clean image
that i'm interested in extracting from
this noisy image
it can actually represented by just a
few simple geometric components
and one extremely extremely
popular and successful type of smoothing
procedure within image processing has
been
for instance the total variation that
enforces a sparsity
by penalizing the l1 norm of the
gradient of use so enforcing sparsity
uh on gradient of the image meaning that
most of the uh image can be well
represented by something where the
gradient of u is zero meaning that u is
constant and just a few characteristic
places we want uh
this is where the important information
is and this is where the edges of the
image are okay
okay so and then there is a
regularization parameter which balances
um how much i'm penalizing my
regularization so how how how how much
i'm penalizing let's say the total
variation against how close you should
stick to the noisy image and this will
in the denoising case depend on noise
level okay
okay and maybe just one word um more
about this is that here i'm representing
this really in a kind of functional
analytic way
but of course um
there is this very strong connection to
uh statistics in particular bayesian
statistics where we can also interpret
this
as a maximum a posteriori estimator um
for u given y
oops for u given y where uh the
regularization uh is derived from the
prior distribution and the data
discrepancy is described uh derived from
the likelihood okay
okay this is as much statistics as you
will get out of me today then uh so now
of course the result will depend this in
this case denoising result will depend a
lot on what i'm going to choose as my
smoothing procedure now i said the total
variation something has been extremely
popular you
also see this kind of piecewise constant
uh flavor that solutions uh have
um
but uh
of course you could choose different
things as well right so so this is
something that has been extremely
popular in inverse problems in general
yeah in uh
is uh is ticking off regularization in
the form of a gradient of u squared
which gives you
um
um
which gives you a homogeneous smoothing
of the image no matter whether there is
an edge or not i'll i'll briefly will
explain in a moment what the difference
is but but this this has definitely won
the race let's say
and
what is it doing just again uh
conceptually we said is
enforcing sparsity on the gradient of
you so just keeping
the edges as the main information left
but what is really you know in 1d it's
very well
it's very nicely explained because it
really the total variation
um
of a 1d signal is just the accumulation
of jumps that you see in this signal and
so oscillations are a killer for the
total variation which you know then
noise are basically oscillations that
you want to get rid of in the image so
the total variation is really good in p
in penalizing such oscillations while
respecting intrinsic image features the
large jumps in the image that are the
edges and again you can interpret
because i'm my background is actually
non-linear pde so so this is also why
pdes are always in the title and pdes
are at the heart of lots of things that
i do and there are also by the way also
at the heart of total variation
regularization of these total variation
variational models um
because you can characterize solutions
on the one hand through looking at their
corresponding optimality conditions
which
in this case will give you a pde
um or you could think of looking even at
the gradient descent
of
such a functional
or
you know because maybe you want to solve
it iteratively through gradient descent
or whatever um or you're interested in
well
there are several reasons why you could
do this but then you also see this
nicely i mean here i've just written it
down and
uh um in uh in the most general way
where uh
because when we do gradient descent
actually we would need to differentiate
this we can't so we need to
actually write this down in terms of a
sub differential inclusion but for those
who for this is unfamiliar let me just
uh give you the other interpretation
which is that
if you look at the derivative of this
for um
a u for which the gradient view is is
non-zero then you can actually see
again the smoothing procedure in terms
of a highly non-linear pde that you are
solving yeah
and
uh where the diffusivity
is dependent on one over the gradient or
one over the modulus of the gradient of
u yeah which means you're diffusing more
when
uh the gradient of u is small so you
have small oscillations and you're
diffusing less if the gradient of you is
large okay
and
so this is what you're also seeing here
here i'm showing the evolution of this
huh
and i mean there are many more things i
could say no but i think i'll i'll stop
here for now so this is this is kind of
the things that are appearing in this
um in in in this knowledge written
domain one example being the total
variation but there are lots more okay
so
uh
i've mentioned harmonic analysis there
of course a lot of this kind of
multi-resolution analysis popping up
there are other regularizers based on
sobolev norm beth of norms there are
various versions of token variation
regularization out there
non-local and isotropic versions um and
so on and so forth so this extremely
rich feel that many people have thought
about the type of regularizes because
they are so important the quality of
these regularize is so important for the
quality of the denoised image of course
and you can go with this beyond
denoising just very briefly speaking by
putting into the data discrepancy term
uh not um the model of y equals u plus n
but uh
uh
putting a so-called forward operator in
that describes uh the measurement
process and how the hue has been
transformed while being measured
and
so this could be for imaging painting
could just be a projection onto
the known domain
for
image blurring could be a convolution
with a kernel with a blurring kernel and
for this image reconstruction from
indirect measurements could be a lot of
different things and here because i'm
just looking here at the linear case
when the operator t is linear
so this examples could be again the
radon transformers in computer
tomography or the fourier transform as
for instance in
magnetic resonance tomography
okay let me jump this because i
yeah so so one really exciting thing i
think also is that the total variation
is so versatile um
that it has even beyond just acting as a
smoother for
the image you can also use this for
segmentation
um
and uh the main reason and i don't have
time to speak about this uh actually uh
is that you can reinterpret or you can
if you look at an image that is super
simple just a characteristic function of
a domain okay a subset
uh of your image domain uh then the
total variation of this is nothing else
in the parameter of this domain okay and
if you now imagine that this this domain
is what you're after is your
segmentation
then you can immediately see that this
has now consequences because you can get
smooth segmentations out of this but let
me
skip this
also for the purpose of this program of
course the really nice thing about this
knowledge driven paradigm is that there
are lots of mathematical um topics that
arise in analysis in uh
non-linear pdes and geometric analysis
um in convex analysis if we go to both
in the continuum and also in
the in in the discretization of these
models
um lots of things appear in optimization
um
convex non-convex yeah lots of things
and of course the main thing in numerix
is is again scalability okay so you want
to do this with very large
um large sized data and
most of the models that you're looking
at are either non-smooth
non-linear
yeah
non-convex so that's what makes this
challenging and they all the
applications we've seen before
actually have
some uh some uh bits and pieces of such
such knowledge driven paradigms in them
so they really
they can really solve these problems
that you've seen before
but there are limits right there are
limits to these types of approaches
and i'm going to wrap up in the next uh
five minutes if that's okay let me just
turn the bell off
there are limits which uh where now the
this data driven my dear come in okay um
and the limits are really let me
actually go uh briefly uh to what we've
seen before the denoising example the
limits are really in terms of capturing
prior information to uh uh to higher
degrees of of accuracy okay
um
because our modeling capacity is just
limited
and
our modeling capacity and also the
capacity of what we can compute in the
end with these models huh
and this is i think easily seen if you
just do the thought experiment of trying
to denoise the cameraman yourself and
comparing it with the total variation
denoised image you know because you know
how
um
the how grass looks like how the sky
looks like you also know how certain
things like the ear and so on should
look like structures there you probably
would be able to do a better job than
what the total variation is doing
and this really suggests that
data-driven models have a role to play
in this context of imaging right because
they can capture prior information and
images very very well
as we have seen in many examples let me
skip this again so let's briefly let me
just show you a few examples of what can
be done with data driven modeling and
here in particular i'm going to for to
show you examples from deep learning
because these are the ones that are
dominating the the field at the moment
okay
and we do we know all of this deep
learning of course emerged because we
have a lot of data that we can learn
from and we can we can actually train
these models we have computing power
okay so what uh can we do and
here this is really impressive i
like to show this image in painting
examples well first of all because that
was really how i grew up in this area my
my first papers i've written on imaging
painting with
fourth order non-linear pdes but now
thinking about what a fourth order
non-linear pde could do to uh
to this uh albert einstein uh example
here versus what you see here a deep
neural network is doing is of course not
comparable right so uh first of all this
is this what you're seeing here is also
a kind of real time so this is extremely
fast and then of course a pde would
never be able to do something like that
or not not a not a pde that i would like
to compute the solution of numerically
at least
um and and and there are other
really exciting examples uh so so here
this is image editing again a form of
impainting i mean a pde without knowing
that eyes should be where where where
where eyes are right
uh would not be able to do this
but the neural network is because it has
seen a lot of faces before
um
okay so this is data driven so this
works super well of course a challenge
that we have
is
that we don't quite
understand
um how these things work
how to systematically design them
um
how to
um to tune them
in certain ways apart from doing trial
and error kind of thing okay so it's
mostly a black box and this is a problem
because of what i've just said okay and
of course also the safety danger which
we all know about yeah
um
so what i believe and this is the note
where i'll finish now where i believe
the most exciting developments are at
the moment happening and don't look too
much at this slide it's not important
what exactly is on there really but is
at this interface
between
data driven approaches like deep neural
networks and
knowledge driven ideas knowledge with
models
where you use uh your
you know all the things
that
we have um you know that mathematical
research has developed over centuries
you use that to make to to uh to derive
better
data-driven models basically okay
uh and for instance here to develop a
deep learning approach for um
for image reconstruction from
tomographic measurements
that
fits within a variational framework that
really also inherits
solution properties existence stability
properties from the variational
framework okay and for which we can also
interpret what this reconstruction looks
like let me skip this because again
performance it it performs very well if
you compare tv reconstruction with the
reconstruction with the kind of
approaches that you can get with
combining variational models with neural
networks is super impressive and on the
left you have the ground truth
okay so uh let me uh stop by just
talking you through some just some take
away messages so mathematical methods
really offer i believe a very powerful
and rigorous toolkit for imaging
we've seen extremely you know diverse
topics ranging from variational models
pdes
i mentioned statistics briefly of course
um
harmonic analysis but you know i left
out even more things like geometry shape
analysis
um
lots of topics i actually didn't touch
upon
and there are so many really uh
cool applications and
where things are really happening at the
moment are at this interface between
knowledge and data-driven approaches and
there are many opportunities for
mathematicians to contribute
thank you very much
okay i'll try to unmute
let's see if this works
between okay now i still hear myself i
don't know how we can do this
um
thank you sorry about that i don't know
what's happening
any questions for carolyn
maybe you can put things in the chat
okay i will try to ask a question i'm
not sure if she'll build here but we'll
figure it out guys
carol can you hear
hi me can you hear me
i think it's because she has her speaker
off
yeah
oh
yeah i don't think i have two mics on
i only have one laptop i don't have a
second computer
i don't know what it is
actually i think they
they
some questions
okay thank you for putting something in
the chat okay uh you mentioned
segmentation quite a bit but do you see
a mathematical framework for
segmentation
okay good point so um
okay so i can tell you one thing where i
mean yes so the short answer is yes i do
um
so
there are several levels where you you
could think mathematics has entered the
picture
even you know on a very high level the
modeling of the unit which is one of the
you know
kind of
main main models uh deep learning models
for segmentation
it is modeled after mathematical
concepts which are multiscale uh
processing multiscale image processing
that you're looking at an image and its
features at different spatial scales
but more concretely
i mean for segmentation for instance um
one one
one ex one one uh one
really important aspect here is again
the size the number of
images that you need to train your
segmentation method with if you use a
pure neural network type of approach
it's often for several applications if
you don't have thousands of trainings
training examples it's unfeasible uh or
which is unfeasible often for
applications like in the medical domain
uh these neural networks all of a sudden
don't perform so very well yeah
i mean i'm generalizing now but in order
to make them work in order to go to
settings where you have a small amount
of training data for instance this again
is where mathematics comes in
yeah we have done for instance some work
on
hybrids between deep learning and
pdes on graphs
where you
basically model the missing information
the information that is missing in terms
of because you don't have such a large
training set you make that up by putting
in more geometric information into
uh into your
clustering into your segmentation
uh algorithm
so
small data regime maybe to be short is
where mathematics comes in and then also
in the design of segmentation approaches
oh yes katie
uh
hello thank you for a wonderful talk
thank you katie actually it's really
good to see you uh just from the
distance
um what guys your choice of data
fidelity term either in the classroom or
yeah okay thanks a lot for the question
because i haven't mentioned this
so in the classical approach the data
discrepancy um particular the
um
the
yep the discrepancy function used uh
depends on the statistics of your data
that you're measuring
so
let's say the um
the l2
the l2 squared fit so the least squares
fit the the l2 norm is often
used
as a good proxy for
normally distributed
for normally distributed data
and again this is again often used
because of
well basically the central limit theorem
um
but other you know if you for instance
have poisson noise then people use the
coolback glible divergence if you have
um
sparse uh sparse noise if you have
impulse noise the l1 norm is used and so
on and so depending on the distribution
of your data you use different
discrepancies
and that's the same for the hybrid
methods as well i would say
all right
further questions i'm happy to type them
are there any more questions from
auditorium that i could type it in
i don't dare to turn on my
nice speaker
okay
all right uh
yeah i think that's it uh
uh
okay let's thank uh kerala for this oh
leon oh nice i didn't [ __ ] you yet in
the audience can you wave for a second
[Laughter]
no maybe maybe you're not in the
audience okay so um
i okay
you're virtual fair enough uh
do you s
which are not learned but modeled
um
[Music]
okay so now it would be so much better
if you could talk but
uh so
i mean to a certain so
i mean to a certain extent what we have
been doing all those years is to model
regularizers right
now
the
paradigm that that we have that the the
the other extreme would be to make them
fully uh
fully data driven
and are you me do you mean to
combine the two to
i mean for instance dictionary learning
is a good
example of combining the two worlds
right
so you say
i assume my regularizer my my prior
is that that my solution is sparse but i
don't know in which
you know in in which representation and
now i'm learning also the representation
but i don't know is this what you mean
what do you mean
sorry
okay thanks
good thanks
thanks for the question
all right uh
let's thank uh kerala vivian for a
wonderful talk
thank you
okay i understand this was thank you
very much thank you thanks a lot for
coming
and thank you prashad for
hosting me and for sharing